6-Mute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6-Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish. I'm Beth.
And I'm Neil.
If you really love something, maybe a sport or a hobby, a music band or a TV show,
you might call yourself a fan.
Nowadays, thanks to the internet, fans from around the world can meet online to share their passion.
And this has led to a new word, fandom.
fandom is more than simply being a fan.
It's a whole culture created by a community of people to share their love of the same thing.
What's more, fandom has started to develop its own language.
In this programme, we'll be taking a trip into the world of fandoms and, as usual,
we'll be learning some new and useful vocabulary too.
But before that, I have a question for you, Neil.
The original word fan was first used about Americans in the early 20th century.
But what were these Americans fans of?
Was it A. Hollywood movie stars, B. Baseball or C. Disney cartoons?
I'll guess they were fans of Disney cartoons.
Okay, Neil. We'll find out later in the programme.
Michael Bond is the author of a new book, Fans.
Here he discusses the meaning of fandom with BBC Radio 4 programme, Word of Mouse.
Often marked, and if you're a Jane Austen fan and you want to dress up in a bonnet and gown of the
Reconcy era, it's difficult to do that by yourself in public.
But once you join a fandom, there's no problem.
Fans are groups of like-minded people.
They share similar opinions, ideas or interests.
They do all kinds of weird and wonderful things together,
such as dressing up as Harry Potter characters,
behaviour, which might be called quirky, an adjective meaning odd or unusual, but in an interesting way.
Unfortunately, this quirky behaviour also means fans sometimes get mocked.
To mock somebody means to insult them by laughing at them in an unkind way.
But this hasn't discouraged fans who have started using new words and phrases to show they belong
to a particular fandom.
Here's Michael Bond again, explaining the meaning of two new words about the behaviour of
football fans to BBC Radio 4 programme, Word of Mouse.
Academics who study fandoms, they love to use acronyms and abbreviations, and they've got
several phrases which they use to describe the behaviour of football fans and burging.
So that means basking in reflected glory.
Oh, I love that.
When your team wins, everyone wants a bit of the action you take to the streets, dance around,
and so the subantithesis of that is core thing, which means cutting off reflected failure.
And that is what people sometimes do when their team loses, and they don't want to be associated
with that loss, that sense of failure.
Burging is made of an acronym of the words basking in reflected glory.
It means feeling good about yourself when the football team use support wins.
Fans say we won, even though it was the players on the pitch, not the fans who scored the goal.
When their team wins, fans cheer and want a piece of the action, an idiom meaning that they take
parts in celebrations and other exciting group activities and feel the success of the team
as a personal success.
The opposite of burging is core thing, another acronym, this time of the words
cutting off reflected failure.
Core thing involves distancing yourself from the team you support when they lose.
Instead of saying we won, you say they played rubbish.
Of course, true fans never core. In fact, some football fans take a kind of strange
pessimistic pleasure when their team loses week after week.
I can't imagine that's true of the Americans you mentioned, Beth,
so what was the correct answer to your question?
I asked who the original word fan was used to describe.
You said it was fans of Disney cartoons, which was the wrong answer I'm afraid.
Actually, it was baseball fans or fanatics as they were called at the time.
Okay, let's recap the vocabulary we've learnt starting with, like,
minded, an adjective describing people who share similar opinions, ideas or interests.
Quirky means odd or unusual, but in an attractive or interesting way.
If you mock someone, you insult and laugh at them in an unkind way.
Burging is short for basking in reflected glory.
It means feeling good about yourself when the team you support wins.
The opposite of this is coughing, an acronym of Cutting off Reflected Failure,
which means distancing yourself from your favourite team when they lose.
And finally, if you want a piece or a slice of the action,
you want to take part in a celebration or other exciting group activity to include yourself
in a collective success. Once again, our six minutes are up.
Join us again next time for more trending topics and useful vocabulary.
Here at six minutes English. Bye for now.
Bye.